optimal room at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking so noil super sentai
[Music]
phonetic organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by Intel and I've used
them personally ever since I wrote the
4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life I use that in investing
as well
the second how can I spend a little
money or moderate money to save
significant time Intel is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
needs
I used Intel during the launch of the
4-hour body which was very very involved
and they provided 24/7 customer service
for my land rush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books and
participated this allowed me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like the marketing plan that
we've worked on for six months
implementing that Intel trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
now and make your customers raving fans
they answer more than a million customer
service requests every year and they can
do so across all platforms including
email phone social media text even chat
leaving your customers with poor service
or just mediocre service which by the
way in a competitive pool is a huge
liability long wait times or unanswered
messages carries a massive cost and risk
to your business Intel removes the
logistics and headaches of this type of
communication allowing you to focus on
your strengths and grow your business it
can be a real competitive advantage and
I see many many e-commerce companies and
tech companies thinking of customer
service as a good enough check
or an afterthought and just like Airbnb
use design and innovative ways to be a
competitor and to win you can do the
same thing with customer service so as a
listener of this podcast you can get up
to ten thousand dollars off a big
discount ten thousand dollars off your
startup fees and costs by visiting Inca
Telecom forward slash Tim so check it
out for more info go to Inc Cal calm i
NK te l comm forward slash tip this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
I've used 99designs for years for all
sorts of graphic design needs whether
you need a logo website cover anything
else 99designs was created to make great
designs accessible to everyone and to
make the process of getting designs much
much easier so when I first started out
for instance
testing prototype covers and getting
prototype covers for the 4-hour body I
went the contest route that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other time zones other countries can
also help you solve that problem since
then I've worked with 99 designs on a
separate path or a different option and
that is the one to one project service
so in a number of cases and I'll give
you one example when I wanted to create
the cover for my audio book the Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate and provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
some incredibly good really some of the
best illustrations I've ever seen from
using this one-to-one project service
with a handful of different designers
and illustrators it blew my mind 99
designs makes this all very easy and
efficient so you can check out the Tao
of Seneca design and other work that I
and your fellow listeners for that
matter have done on 99 designs at 99
designs comm forward slash Tim and right
now you can get a free $99
upgrade on your first design again
that's 99designs dot-com for slash Tim
hello boys and girls mom was in a miss
you way way this is Tim Ferriss
recording in Montreal Quebec the Tim
Ferriss show each and every episode is
focused on deconstructing world-class
performers from all different fields and
this episode features Blake Mycoskie you
can say hi to Blake on the socials
Twitter and so on at Blake Mycoskie my
cos kie we've known each other for quite
a few years
Blake is the founder and chief shoe
giver of Tom's
and that makes him the person behind the
one-for-one business model which helps a
person need with every product that is
purchased but there are many many stats
and some very impressive numbers related
to his bio and his business and we will
get to that shortly I'm going to keep
this initial intro very very short in
this episode we cover a lot we talked
about earlier intrapreneurial ventures
let's try that again in English early on
skype I know really I think that's
French English alright anyway
early entrepreneurial ventures the power
of journaling how the stool analogy
changed Blake's life lessons from Ben
Franklin and much much more this episode
comes from my new television show
fearless ten episodes two full season
where I interview world-class performers
on stage in front of a studio audience
about how they've overcome doubt conquer
fear and made their hardest decisions
you can watch the entire first episode
of this TV show fearless with
illusionist David Blaine where he
actually performs magic on stage with
guests from the audience as well you
watch it for free at att.net forward
slash fearless that's att.net forward
slash fearless to watch all of the
episodes and a lot of them are physical
or involved demos on stage please visit
Direct TV now calm only one T in that
not direct space TV but DirecTV one
we're at DirecTV now calm or you can go
to Tim blog forward slash spear las' and
we recorded three hours of material for
this
particular session with Blake all of it
was awesome
we used one hour for TV so this podcast
episode is not a duplicate it is almost
entirely brand new content that did not
appear on television so I hope you enjoy
this chat as much as I did with Blake
Mycoskie welcome to fearless I'm your
host Tim Ferriss and on this stage will
be deconstructing world-class performers
of all different types uncover the
specific tactics and strategies they've
used overcome doubt tackle their hardest
decisions and ultimately succeed on
their own terms by show of hands how
many of you guys own a few pairs of
shoes that is everybody in the room how
many of you own around 10 pairs of shoes
all right more than a half how many of
you do not own a single pair of shoes
alright that's a big fat zero my guest
tonight has built a company that's given
away more than 60 million pairs of shoes
to those who need them most during a
trip to South America you recognize the
unique opportunity to blend business and
philanthropy since its founding Tom's
has given away millions of shoes helped
restore eyesight and provided safe
drinking water to those in need across
the globe so ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the stage the founder of
Tom's Blake Mycoskie how did your mom
and dad differ in terms of parenting
styles that's a good question I think my
dad was more serious and and more kind
of intellectual and the things that he
taught us and I think my mom was much
more you know kind of hands-on caring I
mean they both were very caring but but
I think that my moms you know kind of
was just so over attentive to our and I
was a first child and so I think the
first child gets that no matter what
family it is because the parents are so
afraid of messing up I know I am I've a
two-year-old so but no but my dad was
always like kind of like the moral you
know kind of you know that he was the
true north in the family and in the II
kind of was the disciplinarian when that
needed to happen and he was kind of the
you know the intellectual I would say
but what was interesting is when my mom
became you know this best-selling author
and every publishing company the world
flying to Arlington Texas to try to
court her and then my dad's realizing
like wow this is like totally changing
our our families you know kind of the
whole dynamic alliance um the cool thing
I think I learned from my dad was like
he like you know cut down on his
practice 50% started supporting her
traveling with her going to do the talk
shows infomercials but he there was a
total role reversal and I think that
really taught me a lot about
relationships because it was like such a
beautiful thing to see even though I
wasn't like in like I wasn't really
understanding all of what I was seeing
at that age but now it was like you know
he she was there putting him through
Medical School
my parents literally used to sell their
blood to go pay the rent they were so
poor during medical school I mean that
if all these stories being in New
Orleans at Tulane and like going in on
my mom always says my dad could get more
money for his blood because there's more
rare than hers and that used to piss her
off
and I call I mean all these things that
she was this she was working you know
you know as a waitress and everything
here and there and everything to put him
through medical school is all about his
career
longest time for the moment that my mom
created something that was just it had
some charity instead of him being
threatened by that which I think a lot
of men would have been he said this is
amazing it's your turn now and and I
think that's my parents been married for
47 years and yeah perfect so I think you
know that was that was something seeing
that was another part of that whole that
whole experience that really had a big
impression on me not only what my mom
created but to support my dad played in
was the cookie stand your first business
experience I think so and that seems
like such a cliche does it there yeah
that was early day cookies uh a little
older when I was selling to myself but I
was trained at a young age you know it
is almost like kind of like one of those
I mean folks there's some great cliches
and entrepreneurship and they're
crochets because they're you know
they're associated for a reason like
having your first business be the
lemonade stand or the cookie stand you
hear that but yeah I mean like I little
older age than that
my mom made these amazing cookies and I
recognized my grandmother lived on a
golf course and so on Saturdays and
Sundays you have you know hundreds of
people who mostly know my grandmother
who was a real character coming through
the golf course and so if i sat there
right on the 8th hole I think she was on
the green and I was you know dressed
cute and all that like I could sell
anything right and a great thing about
this business model was is I convinced
my mom to make all the cookies but did
not charge me for making them so I had
zero cost of goods sold 100% profit
margin a mom as a terrible cook is like
yeah it was a fantastic business why
laughed if I did that a couple summers
so I build up some clientele and they
like the cookie so much that they
wouldn't just buy him for that eating
occasion they would buy him and put him
in the freezer to have for weeks so I
had a pretty good thing going I think
that was about when I was like 9 or 10
but yeah it was that was those the first
I think entrepreneurial venture the
second one was and what very few people
know because it's not a legally been
that
book but my dad when I was 18 freshman
year in college at this point I had
never had a real job as my dad says like
I mean I was training to be a
professional tennis player so every
single day after school I trained from
3:30 til literally bedtime and I was
incredibly obsessed with tennis and my
parents totally supported that but then
when I went to college I was playing
college tennis and and I remember my dad
after the season was over and he said
you know this summer I really think you
need a job I had a younger brother and
sister my brother and sister had like
they were eight years younger and four
years younger they had jobs like the dry
cleaners or the you know the clothing
store at the mall or that all these
different places and they were much
younger than me and and my dad's like
you got a college scholarship you're
doing your thing but this summer like
you need to have a job and I was like
okay like you know I wasn't really
excited about that but I said fine and
it wasn't because I didn't like to work
and it worked really hard but I worked
hard on something I cared about that was
tennis and so I talked to people and
said what's the how can you make the
most amount of money when you're 18
years old in a part-time job because I
still need to practice sense and the
answer I got time and time again was to
get a job at a restaurant that had high
price points but they had a bit of a
pretty quick turnover so not fine dining
but like a you know but a more expensive
restaurant and then kind of fast service
and so there were you asking food but I
I was asking like anyone in college that
I had that I thought was older of me
that had made some money or that had any
any form of you know like Nets work
experience and and in friends of mine
who were older and me in school had done
that and eaten some of them were even
putting themselves through school that
way and so there's this restaurant
called Papa Joe's in Texas I don't know
if you've been there for total people so
it's like seafood anyways it's pretty
expensive but the table turned fast and
so I went and and even though I had no
experience and some people this is their
career I mean this isn't a part-time job
it's that good of a rest
job but luckily the hiring manager is a
huge tennis fan and so we talked about
tennis and she played in college at a
rival school and I was playing at and
all and so I was like I can do this job
I got I mean I really had the cellar on
me doing so I got the job so I came home
and I was like to my dad as like a guide
job not a job I got like a job I want to
make like a lot of money this summer and
into the next part of if you work in a
restaurant is memorizing the menu oh I
hate memorizing things I mean I just
like that it's like the worse for me
like studying and cramming for tests is
not my thing
and so after like a 2 or 3 days I was
like I just this is miserable like I'm
not going to be able to memorize this
menu and I found out you don't even get
paid the first two weeks because it's
training and my summer is only like oh
nine weeks long so I'm like that's like
15% of 19-page so this isn't sounding
less and less appealing every day so
this is where the moment came in I think
this was truly my first entrepreneurial
kind of synapses went off my brain my in
our house next to our house there was a
tennis court and I clearly had you know
learn to become a great tennis player
and I knew that there were a lot of kids
in our neighborhood that could use
tennis lessons and maybe even some other
adults too one intends left and then we
had to send score we could use any time
and I knew how much my parents paid for
tennis lessons for me growing up and
there's a huge investment for me and so
I just said before I go into work this
next week this weekend I made these
flyers and I put SMU college tennis
player you know training for the next
eight weeks kids adults classes the the
whole thing the same way as you'd see it
like a country club and I've made 5,000
fliers and put them in literally took me
like two days every single mailbox in
the entire neighborhood and and then at
that point I had my own phone line and I
put changed my voicemail do like Blake's
tennis camp or something and at Guardian
calls and like within a week I had like
every hour of the day booked and instead
of making like I was charging I was I
think it popped those with tips and
stuff I a verge where I was going to be
making like maybe 14 or 15 dollars an
hour which would have been really good
back then
but teaching tennis because I have each
kid paying like $15 an hour to have five
to the time I was making like 80 bucks
an hour
and so I had to set up my dad came home
he thought I was supposed to be a worker
Papa does and he sees me teaching like a
whole group of kids and my mom
delivering cookies and lemonade to their
parents and you guys what's going on
here and I said you know if this isn't
still a job and and I'm making four
times money than I was so that was the
moment where I really felt like I kind
of started my entrepreneurial journey
did you dad want you to get a job to
earn money or it wasn't because he won't
need you to have the experience of like
reporting to someone else I mean clearly
it was the latter but I Trump it with
earning well you could argue with
writing you'll make up 80 dollars an
hour I mean it was crazy
every time we learn airplane the first
thing I do if it's not getting a cup of
coffee is is start journaling I have I
have a massive safe in my office that
has hundreds and hundreds of journals
we're actually making a documentary film
about the whole Tom's experience and a
big part of the film is going back and
grabbing random urinals and reading
these injuries you're like I can't
believe I was saying this or thinking
this because you tenderly I tended to be
more even though I'd confess all my
fears I tended to kind of use the
journal as a way of positively setting
the tone of the next day the next week
the next month you know and it's
something that I love doing him and it's
something I'm really glad I did because
I think it helps me understand my life
which i think is good because
understanding your past is how you can
really think be more proactive for your
future totally I have so this is a
shared habit so I have probably about
eight bookshelves worth of journals yeah
I've kept them all since around the same
age 15-16 but it started with
weightlifting yeah thing I wanted to
track my progress and to be able to
understand what worth what and so on but
it's turned into what I've heard
described I think her name is Julia
Cameron she wrote a book called the
artists way she described journaling the
first type the confessional
yeah as spiritual windshield wipers
meaning you get that down especially in
morning hi and the way I look at us are
trapping my monkey mind and my anxieties
on the page yes that I can get on with
the day
yeah and the morning journaling habit
was actually introduced to me by and by
the way guys like the act the morning
journaling specifically isn't something
I started until that I want to say three
years ago at the recommendation because
I think there's a lot of people I have
been journaling for a long time and then
I stopped for a while yeah and I would
only use it for goal so yeah it's just
what I didn't do that other yeah which I
think so so critical and I was like hey
that's like the rah-rah positive
thinking like I don't even get it all
the secret widow like I don't know with
it so I then ran into a guy named Brian
Koppelman who's a screenwriter
along with his writing partner they did
The Illusionist solitary man Ocean's
thirteen billions the co-creators of
that show which is a current huge hit
he does it every morning yeah and he
said you have to start mourning
everything so since it was coming from
him
yeah I started and it was immediate
that's the difference and not just my
performance but also my well-being well
I think it wasn't heard the spiritual
windshield wiper which I like that that
term because that's what it kind of does
for me is it it in anything that is like
like controlling my thoughts like
stress-related or like you know or I
feel like I have too many things in my
mind or my to-do list or everything once
I get on the page then I can just like
singularly focus on the most important
things of the day you know and I know
you've spoken about like do the two most
important things right away in your day
and by journaling a healthy organized
what are those really things because
when you're writing about it you kind of
it starts you know whatever's getting
the most attention typically is the
thing you don't want to have to do with
it you need to do but it but it really
does I think help you clean your day and
at the end of the day too
I think it also can serve as a way to
kind of allow yourself to relax and get
ready for for bed and like get over with
the day if you've had some stuff on your
mind
so it's interesting about writing it you
would think it would make it even more
something you'd be thinking about but I
find like once I've written it and I let
it go and I close the book it's
the problems are in the book and they're
no longer with me and the oldest and if
it's a positive thing then I think it is
potentially reinforcing them I never
forget this they're so interesting how
going back to these little moments in
your life that can really change
trajectory and I often times it can be
someone that you meet or you hear listen
or listen to or a book you read so there
was a guy named Bob Dedmon and Bob devon
has passed now but I'm he was a
self-made billionaire and he gave more
money to SMU in University of Texas I
think than anyone ever
he literally grew up in a trailer park
and he started off as a lawyer and then
ultimately where he made his real
fortune was you recognize that golf
clubs country clubs were becoming more
and more popular in the 70s in the 80s
but it was very expensive to maintain
the golf course and the restaurant and
everything and you made money by selling
the real estate around it so what he
started doing is creating clubs with
multiple courses but one crew that could
service multiple courses so now you only
need one greenskeeper for three clubs
and three times the amount of real
estate sales one kitchen in all these
things and it became to think of club
corpses when he passed away he was the
largest owner of golf golf courses and
tennis courts in the world and he's this
amazing guy and he lives in Dallas Texas
and he loved tennis so he'd come out and
watch our tennis matches and he was that
eccentric billionaire guide watch our
tennis matches and and for whatever
reason I forget what it was I think it
was raining we couldn't practice that
day and our coach said you know what you
guys have seen mr. Dedmon many times
watching the matches since rain today we
can't practice we're going to watch a
video of a commencement speech that he
gave for the MBA program at University
of Texas a couple weeks ago and just so
you can have some more frame of
reference of how wise this guy is and
you the speech was basically about
having a life path and thinking of your
life is a stool and every stool has
three or four legs and what are they
going to be the legs of your life
whatever your path I mean one is your
talents one is your interest one is you
know all these different things I can
exactly was but I remember leaving that
day and I just hurt myself thinking you
know I don't think my stool is going to
be a professional tennis player and I
actually think my life is about other
things and I started recognizing these
kind of palates
you know talents was definitely
self-discipline and all these different
things and so I remember watching that
video and having peace that the idea of
not continuing down the tennis path
another great Ben Franklin story that
I've read that actually had a huge
impact on early days of Tom's I was
reading the biography one of the ones
many written and so when he had the
Farmers Almanac right and that was a lot
bill don't recognize that that is that's
how he made his first fortune was was
through the Almanac and most of the
things we know Ben Franklin for actually
happened after he retired age forty so
he sold the Farmers Almanac had money at
the time retired and then all the
mentions and then came out of the
curiosities afterwards but what my
favorite stories was is there was this
person that went advertised in the
Farmers Almanac and Ben Franklin did not
agree with his ethics and his morals and
his ideals but he needed to take
advertising money to keep his Almanac
going and so what he decided to do was
that night he instead of sleeping in his
bed in his home he slept in his office
on the floor with only a piece of bread
to eat and he woke up the next morning
and was just as happy as he was the day
before and that's when he said he would
never take advertising dollars from
someone he didn't believe with and so
that was a huge thing with me with
earlier Tom's like we will we will say a
hundred percent focused on the mission
whether we make it or not because we're
going to be we're going to be happier
doing it the way we feel that was is the
right thing to do than cutting corners
to make extra money and that when I read
that that was a few cents so
now I was just going to say not only
that but that you can live with the
worst-case scenario is that right now is
that's that's what he proved so this is
gone so we're going to keep kind of
peeling back the onion here because I
mentioned stoicism earlier part of the
reason I suspect Ben Franklin did that
is he was a huge Seneca fan yes and
Seneca specifically he has a collection
of letters called the morale letters to
Luke Ilyas don't worry this is going to
be long
and that there's letter I think it's
thirteen called on feasting on festivals
and fasting that's it
and I know the name because I've read it
so many times and part of it is set
aside a few days I'm making up the time
period every month where you will go
with deed the cheapest of dress the
scanty stuff air sort of the roughest of
bed yeah asking yourself all the while
is this the condition I so feared yes
and I have a close buddy Kevin Kelly
who's amazing Kevin Kelly is the
founding editor of Wired magazine and
has done a million just incredible
things and what he would say to himself
to kind of bring it into contemporary
times because he'd spent a lot of time
backpacking as a kid and he was like I
was always thrilled even it's just like
a dirtbag college student backpacker
to have sleeping bag and oatmeal he's
like as long as I'm sleeping bag no no
yeah I'm fine I don't have to sell out
so this isn't selling out this is
dropping it and and so but I had started
this thing and it was it was kind of
working and I had employees and I had
this responsibility and that felt much
more real than going to class like you
know talking about Descartes or whoever
whatever philosopher I was talking about
at the time and so I I remember calling
my dad and I was really nervous because
my dad as we talked about before you
know is this just really accomplished
doctor you know did I mean how many
years of school college medical school
you know residency I mean he is like
made a life of Education and I was going
to tell him after 18 months that I was
gonna drop out of college and and I was
also the oldest grandchild of all my
other cousins and stuff too so I was
like the one everyone was looking at you
know
uh and you know his response to that was
was like the most amazing into this day
I still kind of baffled to understand
how his response was this way but he
basically said you know you've taken on
this thing you have a responsibility now
to a lot of people and it seems like
you're having a lot of fun and so I
think it's a great idea and I was just
like the joke like I'm a script I've
been working like a month on the
preparation for this call like I was
scared to do it in person
like I did it and even though my parents
we lived an hour away like I was a phone
call just because at any point in time I
need just to hang up and get out of it I
could and he was totally supportive and
and I think you know it's a big
testimony to my dad and kind of his
belief of like giving people the chance
to fail and to learn and but it was it
was an amazing point because his
confidence or his ability for me to kind
of be curious and try something and then
also him stressing how I had really now
that I had employees I had taken on more
responsibilities than just doing
something for myself it was bigger than
just me right and that has really stayed
with me through all the different
businesses and I think that's why we
invest so much in our employees of Tom's
and and their full well-being not just
in their financial well-being and also
the point was my dad and I made them to
was I was going to be on my own
financially so if I dropped out like I
was being supported by my parents when I
was in college is most a lot of kids are
not every kid has that that fortune but
I have many of the kids in my score busy
okay if you're dropping out like your
business needs to support you like you
need to be able to support yourself and
so that was a real difficult reality at
first to and which created a lot of fear
and a lot of like oh my gosh now like I
have to make this work because my
parents aren't supporting me more and
and but that also is a great motivation
I think that was a great move on his
part
yeah I got to keep your feet to the fire
right yeah losing sit no parental safety
net
one of the things a question I get all
the time when I speak at universities
now is they talked about people choosing
to become entrepreneurs and and I think
in my opinion and a lot of people will
disagree with me that that is you cannot
choose to be an entrepreneur like you
choose to be a lawyer or a doctor or a
teacher like I mean if you go into a
saying okay I'm going to study
entrepreneurship and my career path is
becoming an entrepreneur that is I think
a recipe sometimes for disaster because
then what happens if you've chosen that
path and you don't have anything that's
bothering you you don't have any itches
you need to scratch then all of a sudden
you're you're looking at the world of
like how can I make money how can I
create something that people want but
it's never really your want it's never
really you're dying passion your thing
that you're willing to sacrifice
everything to solve in the world and so
you end up creating a business that is
to make money and to do all these things
they taught you in entrepreneurial
textbooks but it doesn't ever have that
that same intensity of the person that
just is trying to solve a problem and
then ends up creating a business yeah
it's I should point out - this is really
this super important this is a spoke in
the classes as well the balance prayer
ship and you there are cases of people
say dropping out of college and becoming
few successes right yeah but they're
also a lot who do not of course right so
it's not necessarily causation now and
then you also have a lot of people who
say go to a Harvard MBA program and they
do go in to become an entrepreneur and
there are successful examples but my
position has always been exactly what
you said if I'm at least scratching my
own itch I know for a fact there is one
cuff got out no matter of fact there's
one consequence I quit before our work
we do my first book I I went in to find
the book but ya offered it and I
couldn't find out like I there's Jack
Welch over here how to build a fortune
500 company not interested then there's
like money is not important give away
everything I'm like not sure I mean that
can't be either yeah where's the thing
in the middle and so that was just going
to be a collection of those experiments
yeah for myself my car either way yeah I
mean I since you brought up I want to
make sure at least I was able to say
this
on the show is like I mean I read 4-hour
workweek right when I started tops and
there's so many things that I took from
that book that allowed Tom's to have
this incredible growth with we never had
investors which is like unheard of when
you go from zero to 500 million in seven
years and and the reason we were able to
build so rapidly as we outsource so many
things and I never would have understood
how you could operate so lean had I not
read that book so you have I think that
I'd send too many pictures of the over
the years of me going like this is the
number four because and it's usually
like when I'm sailing or playing polo or
doing something fun cuz I'm like there's
a lot of people that we've outsourced a
lot of this work to they're working
really hard right now but I'm not and
things are contained into three and and
I know that wasn't the only purpose of
the book but it really made an impact on
me and a lot of our early staff all read
it because when you're building a
company when you try to do everything
yourself it's really hard to grow as
fast as you as you can but the minute
you've got to let go of some that
control and your outsourcing is many
different things you can yeah your
margin might not be the same initially
but you can prove the model you can get
the top-line sales and you can always
come back and improve the margin later
by bringing a stuff in-house but anyway
thank you oh thank you that makes my day
so one of the things I think one of the
negatives of starting as an entrepreneur
age 18 is you're so focused on your work
you have very little time for other
stuff in your life and I was seeing that
my friends were having these much more
kind of fun social lives than me because
I was working all the time so the way
that I was kind of made a deal with
myself was and that was my way of still
having some form of balance in my life I
think the word balance and that we can
have a whole you know to our
conversation about the concept of
balance because I think that you know
people look at it so many different ways
but for me the only way I could even
have a thought of balance was this 11
months you know just like going crazy as
a networking as entrepreneur than that
month off in this place it's so my
sister and I biz all these amazing
countries on The Amazing Race and one of
the countries we kind of quick
went through was Brazil and Argentina
and and I always liked like really
immersing myself in whatever that
country was known for so I got a
guidebook and as you know very well the
first thing that that came up and that
Argentine is known for is the tango I'm
telling you and and so I had not read
your book yet and so I didn't know that
it was possible to learn the tango at
the level that you did I was a little
bit I guess more well I just didn't have
the rhythm of the dancing skills and in
frankly I didn't want to spend my month
off learning something that I probably
thought I would never use again so I
decided not to do tango instead I turned
to horse polo I grew up in Texas had
ridden horses before Argentine is really
well known for polo I don't is a very
romantic cool like just adrenaline you
know sport and so I kind of signed up
for polo camp and so it's called Letarte
day and so I got there and you know
after you know after being there for a
few days so I loved I mean it was I got
[ __ ] off a horse a bunch almost was a
hospital the first week like it was
dangerous but it was like a good danger
like it was just like every morning I
was like I'm going to tackle this horse
and I'm going to hit this ball and and
so I did that for a couple weeks but the
other thing that Argentina is really
well known for is their Malbec white you
know and
and if you like to drink red wine
Malbecs are fantastic and they and so I
decided to spend when I wasn't playing
polo of time in these different
vineyards and and in wine cafes and so
so in the wine cafes is when I
ultimately met a few women that were
doing some volunteer work which
ultimately led to kind of the idea that
there are all these kids that didn't
have shoes I'm jumping a little forward
in the story but I chose Argentina
ultimately because it was my way of
taking a month off and recharging and
learning something new which was Pola so
but let's jump right into it okay you
mentioned meeting these women yeah so
I'm you know this is like I've been in
Argentina for about three weeks you know
we've been here you have Wayne Osiris
which is an amazing city and there's
some poverty and homeless and all the
same things we have problems in our
major cities in the United States but
you go an hour outside or even two hours
outside the city where we were going a
lot for the horses and the fields by
polo and as I was seeing this in
cactuses going to and from the city
almost every day for the Polo and for
getting out to the farms I think it was
it was having an impression on me
but it wasn't something that was leading
to like an action you know it was just
kind of like gosh this this is really
intense this is really sad like I can't
believe this much of poverty just an
hour from this great city now almost
everyone was speaking Spanish the whole
time I was there I was trying to learn
it but I was not doing a good job Matt
could kind of get around with Spanish
that I learned in three weeks but it was
getting exhausting I mean you you're
much better at learning languages and
learn very quickly as we know from
reading your books but for me I had not
been blessed with that ability yet and
so I was just like sitting at dinners
most nights listening to everyone speak
Spanish it was like Charlie Brown's
teachers like object playing I'm in
total solitaire my head until they
finally would you know someone just
beginner's that's the question so when I
hear three women speaking English I'm
just like you know you know be on honey
I'm like whoa
what are you guys doing the Diane like
it's so fun and talk to these women and
so they had been there for about the
same amount of time as me through from
the US one was from the UK and and so
they were going around to wealthy
families in Buenos Aires collecting
these slightly issues and then taking
them to these these towns and these
villages outside the city worked as nude
shoes and it was amazing because I just
been like for three weeks seeing kids on
the streets not in school clearly and
not wearing shoes and and I was and I
was amazed by the fact that this was
like the limiting factor in their
education but also believed it because
I've seen all these all these kids on
the streets and so we know I'm a very
curious person and and I've been playing
polo for three weeks and I was kind of
like looking for something more to round
out my month experience and so I said
that's it like I've never done anything
like this but can I come and help some
way you know I mean dream is
distributing all these shoes the next
week like can you just use another
hands miss it absolutely we love very
easy common and we got there the kids
had been told that they were going to
get chooses days there's always
incredible excitement in the air
and when we pulled in I mean the kids
and some of the parents just started
like kind of just appearing from all
these nooks and crannies in this and
this town that was kind of right next to
a garbage job I mean exactly what you
can picture if you've seen Slumdog
Millionaire I mean that's what it is
that what it felt like
but there was an incredible excitement
enthusiasm because they're getting these
shoes and it's hard because the kids a
lot of them most of them didn't even
know what size they were because all
they had was like a pair of flip-flops
and they didn't have a proper shoe and
so trying to get them fitted in under
Cena that was the challenge but we
worked through it and after we got all
the kids at shoes we played soccer and
you know and had a great day
that's like say it is like like that's
pretty cool music was actually kind of
you know it was a mercy thought it was
cool that anyone was doing this but
these kids because he knew the area but
second he thought it was it was it was a
nice gesture and so I was talking about
how awesome it was and how excited and
how much fun and and he was listening
really intently and and this time Liz
Union guys 23 years old great polo
player and he's kind of listening and
and I mean he got so excited I mean that
kind of his enthusiasm the reason I'm
pretty much sitting here because he's
like this is an amazing idea we have to
do this just to put in perspective foods
of the Argentine's especially the
birthday knows yeah who live in copy
done fitted on in Buenos Aires they're a
mixture of all sorts of immigrant Bloods
you've got like a lot of Italian which
is where they get to look at yeah they
got a lotta time they got a little bit
of German and then all sorts of other
bits and pieces but yeah it's a very
enthusiastic Bunch yes
and so leo you know professional polo
player 23 years old doesn't know a thing
about shoes tells me it's not it first
is not weird you have to do this like
like your idea you do it you think but I
will help you know I I will figure this
out you know and so literally by lunch
you know I mean he this is a guy who has
two cell phones not because he has a
work phone
postponed because he has two
conversations going on at all times I
mean it's like he's talking to so-and-so
his brother and Sons his cousin and
someone's in the vision and it's all in
Spanish not understand anything he's
saying but it it's with enthusiasm they
don't yell at me rivers up it's like
this is what's happening and so by lunch
he had already figured out some one
friend of a friend who made a forgot is
like in their garage you know an hour
away and and and like before I can even
say no like we're going I mean it's it's
like yeah I mean you're in this and I'm
just to leave in like four days and and
so you know in that long car ride there
and back because we really kind of
talked about it like my entrepreneur
brain sort of thing is like you know I
think this I think this could work
because first off I've been wearing this
out forgot I love it it's like super
lightweight super comfortable if it gets
wet it drives right away and there's
nothing like this I mean the only shoes
that are in this kind of canvas slip on
are like converse or vans and they're
heavier and they're clunkier and and
I've windows all these years but this is
a different so I started to really kind
of fall in love with the product as well
as the idea and and then I recognized
that like this didn't have to the first
time I had an idea in my life that I
didn't think of as a business really
even though I was structuring it is
we're gonna sell something and give
something and it's going to be a
business not a charity I didn't think of
like I need to do this to make money
like I had made some money I the
driver's ed business was going great
like that you know it just is just or
sales or just skyrocketing I'm a little
bit less interested in like starting a
business to make money and but I'm
really thinking this could be fun and
that's the thing I always try to like
make sure that people really understand
in terms of the beginning motivation it
was this is I was connected to these
kids and I think we I think this could
work and help them and Esmee a ton of
fun because now is going to go back to
Argentina four times a year I mean this
is a great excuse to go in this country
that fall in love with and Alejo is so
fun and other people were you know so
long story short we get you know would
get to the sky you know and he's and
we're telling him like no we don't want
a fur goddess we want to have like a
nice insole and arch support and all
these things they're going to make
shoe cost like five times as much money
and he's like no one will ever buy this
like no and whatever buy this is too
expensive and I'm like no but we got to
make it instead of last long these
things wear out a couple of weeks and
like oh and just things that even though
I had no experience in shoes that just
as a customer I would want this shoe to
look this way but I'd want to perform a
different way and so it is so you know
after a couple days going back and forth
and meanwhile I've now called my
partners of the driver's ed business and
told them it's not going to be a
one-month vacation but two months this
year and so I'm taking I'm going to take
another couple weeks see if I can figure
out this shoe thing and I hadn't told
any of my friends what I was thinking of
doing or anyone and and I you know I
just I just started like calling you
know my sister and girlfriends and and
in in friends of mine that I thought you
know would appreciate this shoe and not
telling them the story initially that
was one of the key points so selling the
product on the products where I knew
that I knew that the story would get
people excited but I didn't want to like
really go into making this adventure
unless I felt the product could stand on
its own and so in plus I also didn't
know how much to charge so I needed to
kind of get people to reaction like do
you like it number one number two how
much would you pay for it you know
because it was such a different shoe
than anything else out there um and so I
spent a week or two really doing that
because yeah that you so see you you
seem to have a long history of doing
market research by asking with it yeah
you got mistake we didn't even cover
though they buy most of all you get like
to say we didn't even cover the Theta
Sorority yeah like collaboration with
easy longer that's a whole separate
episode but did you ask primarily women
about I did even though I didn't think
it was I thought men and women would buy
the shoes but I just felt like I didn't
know it very much at all about shoes in
my life at that point I knew nothing but
I did know is that every woman in my
life spent a lot of money and time on
shoes yeah like I mean whether it was my
mom my sister my girlfriend
they're always buying shoes yeah I never
really saw my guy friends buying shoes I
mean obviously they had to but they wore
shoes but it wasn't like they talked
about it so I figured like let's
go where yeah this conversations already
happening yeah let's just enter into the
conversation right and so that's why
initially my kind of quick market
research was with women but it was so
cool because I remember this time I had
several girls over to the house or the
apartment at a time Venice and they
thought they're coming off like this
dinner party that I was going to arrange
but instead I had all these shoes on the
table and I and I and they were like
what's going on I was like well we're
gonna have dinner but before I want to
show you earn your dinner yeah it's our
here's your dinner there is no free
dinner is I is I want to hear what you
think about these shoes because I'm
thinking of selling them they come from
Argentina and I didn't tell him about
the story and as I saw them in my living
room trying them on and getting pretty
positive feedback of their cue they're
comfortable I wear them with this I mean
they were kind of talking amongst
themselves then I pulled out a bunch of
photos from my trip in his village and I
told him the story and this point I've
never seen women so excited by a pair of
shoes I mean they bought like three
pairs each I mean they were like telling
me like oh I'm going to call my friend
she's got to get it I mean it was like
this just like you need a friend feeding
frenzy and it was because of the story
is because of the idea of one for one is
because up into that point they had
never been offered an opportunity to buy
something for themselves they usually
feel guilty about right because I mean
women buying shoes it doesn't always you
know end in happiness a lot of it's
guilt because they have too many already
this time there had no guilt it was like
the guilt free shopping of the century
right so so they were buying multiple
payers they were telling me other other
girlfriends of theirs they would get to
buy some of the girls worked in PR and
were telling what stores to be in I mean
it was just like immediately I was like
wow we've stumbled mean it was like I
hit a nerve yeah and and so that was
really encouraging and that's what kind
of got the initial kind of the initial
sales going and helped me figure out how
much the charge form an interesting
thing about the charging and this is I
think is like at some level why in the
dictionary under the word Karma
there should be a picture of Tom's is
you know we charged we we create a model
that was basically to break
not to make money it's really okay we
want our whole goal was to get as many
kids issues possible so we wanted to
charge a price that would be the least
amount that we could charge a customer
and still be able to pay for another
pair of shoes and have an organization
so even though we weren't a non-profit
we went into the thinking that we're not
really profit is not the motivation
you're maximizing your margin yes so but
the thing is is we were making all the
shoes by hand and garages in Argentina
which turns out is very expensive
right so so we're making issues of when
when Tom started to take off and all of
a sudden we were selling not you know
100 pairs here and there but thousands
tens of thousands and then millions we
started large-scale manufacturing our
costs went from here to here it all
suddenly this hugely profitable business
how did we gather begin you I mean it
was truly I have never forget that all
properly it was an it really was this
crazy moment when I was met with this
factory when the first time we were
moving from like garage as a factory and
I was like so how much prepare and he
gave me a price I'm like that for per
shoe or prepare my guys crazy how much
less it was and then we realized okay we
can do the giving we can do that and we
can have a good business and we can make
money and that was like that was the aha
moment of okay this is what I'm going to
you know put all my energy by so in the
very beginning what what names did you
consider for the company and how did it
end up on top yeah that's a great
question so and how many people think
your name is Tom most people that's
another one class
I mean you know that Tim's a great
interviewer because it's been an hour
and 45 minutes until he's asking that
question nine times out of ten that's
the leading first question because it's
so odd so the name Tom so I wore this
shoe today in particular because a is
one of my favorite shoes we've ever made
and it's also when the first is we ever
made 10 years yet and and and and and so
what happened was is I originally called
them tomorrow's shoes and the reason
they were called tomorrow shoes is that
we thought we could make a better
tomorrow by selling a pair today and
giving a pair tomorrow so that was our
our pitch was if you buy a pair today we
promise you that we will give a pair
tomorrow to a child in need and so thank
you and so that was so for the first
couple weeks they were called tomorrow
shoes were down in Argentina or making
them whatever and then we start looking
at all the other kind of casual shoes in
the market so now we're starting to
think about it's a little bit more like
okay we got it you know we got to figure
out like how we're going to brand this
thing and and so we're looking at the
shoe and this two particular there's not
a lot of places to brand it but the most
natural place would be on the back and
there's no way I could fit the word
tomorrow's on the back of the shoe it
just wouldn't fit no matter how little
the font got so I said okay we'll call
it Tom's shoes for a better tomorrow
and so Tom's coming from the word
tomorrow and we chose the Argentine flag
because that's where they were being
made and we got rid of the Sun and put
the Tom's in there and you know and
that's how it that's how it started and
that's how the name came but you know
it's funny because I mean literally
instead of this day people call me Tom
and especially in the beginning and
before anyone knew what I look like and
they just assumed that there was this
Tom and out and one of my favorite
favorite stories is uh in order to sell
the shoes you know it's like anything
else that entrepreneur like the story is
as important as the product you got to
make sure you have a good product but
you know you've got to convey your
enthusiasm and so when I first got into
Nordstrom which is pretty early
considering how small business we were
they said well
well sire shoes in these stores in like
Southern California but you have to
commit to going like every Saturday
Emily's sitting there next to him and
like telling the story because the story
was what was so interesting and I said
fine okay I'll do whatever you know like
this so I would go and I never forget
this one manager I got there on Saturday
morning bright early I'm all excited and
I'm like hey I'm Blake I'm here for to
sell the TOMS shoes the shushing means
good oh man we have a problem now it's
like what functions we've been
advertising for like a week that Tom's
coming and I was like I am called so so
I used to carry my laptop everyone like
quickly have it up like that so you
think tom is look that's me like things
are the times that we live in right now
it's very romanticized to go out and
raise hundreds of millions of dollars in
venture financing with something very
complicated yeah the businesses that
have worked for you that we've talked
about started off addressing a
frustration or in need of your own
simple and low capital requirements at
least in the very beginning no the only
business I ever raise money for was the
business that failed and that was the
reality Channel yeah so I mean that was
the thing about Tom's as we never raised
money and and because we started small
250 pairs it was a thousand pairs this
is two thousand pairs and as we started
growing we were able to you know to you
know bank loans and things like that to
finance inventory but I mean that's one
of the things I think they allowed us to
preserve who we are today 10 years later
and 75 million shoes given and all these
things happen because we didn't have
that influence that comes from investors
and then their demands and how fast you
got to grow and things you got to do so
I always say to entrepreneurs like there
are some businesses inherently you have
to raise money for but though every day
if you have a good idea and you can
execute every day you wake your idea and
your company becomes more valuable and
the more leverage you have and the more
leverage you have
the first time I saw someone wearing
Tom's like a really special moment you
know it's kind of like maybe an artist
the first time sees their painting
hanging in the gallery you know I mean
anyone who's bitten is created something
of any magnitude is proud when they see
it especially they see it on someone
that's a stranger that bought it without
you like begging them on the floor of
Norwich right so about four or five
months after we started Tom's and this
is before we even in Nordstrom when
selling them online and mainly the only
or the only people I've seen wearing
them are my neighbors because all of our
neighbors in the neighborhood thought it
was cool that we were kind of running
this shoe company out of the apartment
in Venice they were buying them my
interns and my family of course and and
and I was in New York City and I would
had actually had a very bad week I'd
gone trying to get new customers like
retailers like the American Rag and I
just struck out like I mean New Yorkers
everyone to have nothing to do with this
shoe and and so I was going back to LA
kind of a little bit with my you know
tail between my legs I was I wasn't even
wearing Tom's wearing some you know
running shoes or something cause I'd
gone for a run in the park earlier that
morning and there's like rushing to the
airport and I get to the American
Airlines check-in counter and I'm doing
the kiosk and not checking bags just
doing it quickly and I look to my right
and there's this woman and she's wearing
a red pair of Tom's mid-30s like wearing
a pair of jeans pair of red toms and I'm
like super excited and but I'm about the
same time I'm like really curious to
like where'd you get those what do you
think about like I mean my my marketing
head my focus group head just go
straight to it and so I say excuse me
um I couldn't help but notice these red
shoes are wearing they're they're really
cool what are they and I'm still doing
the checking because I don't act like
I'm too interested right and give it
away and she looks at me in her eyes
kind of widen and she goes there Tom's
TOMS shoes
oh that's cool you know and that's great
and I'm kind of like just taking is you
kind of waiting sue she says and in that
and I could tell she's like looking at
me like no I have more to tell so I kind
of turned her and and she looks at me
like really intelligence cuz no I don't
think you understand this
the most amazing company in the world
when I bought this pair of shoes they
gave a pair to a child in Argentina and
I really like initially contentious and
there's this guy he lives in off the
angel as' I think he lives on a boat and
he's eight feet tall
she literally starts telling me my life
story
word for word like with more passion in
my mom told I mean it was incredible and
so she's going on and on about this and
that is and at some point that's like oh
my gosh like I have to tell her who I am
now and like there's other people
listening I mean she's animated and so I
say do I say excuse me actually sorry
ruff but um you know I'm Blake
I started toms and she just pod is like
deer in headlights I mean you could hear
a pin drop she looks at me she looks me
again she goes why did you cut your hair
[Applause]
but the interesting thing about that
question and when I learned a huge
business lesson in this question the
reason she knew I cut my hair is she had
watched every video on YouTube about our
shoe giving wow this is right 2006 right
when YouTube same year YouTube launched
and because you know there wasn't a lot
of content on there our videos got a lot
of views back then because there wasn't
and she had watched it and seen it and
so I realized this was just a customer I
mean she took the time out of her
check-in to tell me the entire story I'm
choosing Vangelis for Tom and and so I
got so much that like she you know kind
of didn't recognize because I had cut my
hair short like this and before the
video was really long and bushy and so
it was so funny because on the way home
I realized like we didn't need to focus
on marketing and advocate
that's not what got this girl to buy a
pair of shoes we need to focus on doing
our giving and making sure that content
was easily shareable with our customers
because if she was this passionate to
tell a stranger at the airport surely
she had posted on Facebook about it
tweeted about it probably bought a pair
for her friend for Christmas or whatever
and so it was an amazing experience for
me and it really has kind of
dictated our whole philosophy on
marketing for the past ten years and
that is if we do what we say we're going
to do and we create interesting content
that allows our customers to share with
pride what they've done because it's
really them and we set it up but unless
we sell shoes we don't give them away so
it's what they've done then the momentum
can build and I think that's why we had
this exponential growth so this is this
is a related one this is actually from
the extended family known as the
internet uh hey drew look this is not
like the drunk angry uncle I think this
is a nice herb member of that Christmas
party so Daniel Roddick I think that's
his name and I'm going to shrimp's a
little bit but there's a term I've heard
used before called wfi OMA mispronounced
with you which stands for we're [ __ ]
it's over and you know essentially when
your business seems like it's on the
brink of death of failure running out of
cash PR crisis move by competitor
etcetera etcetera etcetera so the
question and it goes on this is a long
question but I was just wondering if you
had any particular example savea's yeah
from Tubbs if there were any sort of
existential threats when you're like oh
boy there's there's one just I mean is
clear as day this is a in the second
year we now have made that transition
from making human garages to a big
factory and knowing nothing about how to
negotiate with factories and factories
can smell naivete like a mile away we
totally got screwed over by a factory
and we had taken all these big orders we
had taken all the cash that we had I
mean not just toms but like me
personally out of my personal checking
account the orderly issues knowing that
we were going to sell them for a profit
and then we would be able to and so it's
just a the cash flow thing and I never
forget my dad and it was actually the
day I was getting the sailboat that I
was going to live on I lived on a
sailboat for six years it's a whole
nother story about essentialism and and
not having stuff you don't need in your
life and simplifying your life which I
was very intent on doing after spending
so much time in Argentina so I'm going
to get the boat with my dad like
supposed to be a great day in my life
and I get a call and it's Shaun actually
the guy you saw
and he's like we have a problem not what
is like every single soul on the shoes
or falling off like they're not like not
good quality like they're falling off
like the glue they use the factory got
hot on the way here or whatever is like
it's disintegrating and like all these
people were expecting their shoes and
all your money is in this and like we
don't have money to order my shoes I
mean it was definitely a with you hope
moment if there ever was one and and you
know it was it was I I really did think
it was going to be over because I mean
it was like it was it was it was just
with one we're going to college people
and so we didn't able to deliver and it
would take weeks not months to get them
and this is at the point which we now
have big customers you know like the
Urban Outfitters and Nordstrom's and
they don't just like take this news
lightly and the second was is all our
cash was in there I mean there was no
more cash stored and receives I mean
ultimately the way we saved it was we
were able to convince another factory
that if they would make the shoes
without any initial payment that we
would be able to pay them within 90 days
and we would switch all of our business
to them and they did and they were a
great factory for a long time but I
didn't even know there was a possibility
that that came after like days of like
probably heavy drinking in life you know
putting myself in a hole and which I
shouldn't come out but yeah I mean I
think every business has that and
ultimately if you get through it it
makes you stronger yeah
but the truth is it probably kills a lot
of businesses do in retrospect were
there any warning signs or anything that
you could have other ways you could have
avoided that in that particular case I
don't think so because we didn't have
the brand reputation or the cash flow to
have any leverage over factories but we
needed factories and at the same time I
just we didn't have the experience level
to know how to protect ourselves now in
hindsight there's lots of things you can
do to protect yourself with factories
and payment terms and all these things
so I think it was just a situation where
we were unlucky
and in a factory kind of took advantage
of us and they probably thought they
would never get another order anyways so
they didn't take it too seriously and so
if you were advising somebody and I know
this can be small percentage of the
audience yeah but actually I made a
growing percentage we have people now
launching businesses on Kickstarter okay
good news bad news right yeah we've
never made anything but we have five
thousand orders yeah so we've told a
really good story yeah what advice would
you give to someone who's looking at
manufacturing mm the first time I mean I
would say the best thing to do when
you're manufacturing for the first time
is have the manufacturing is close to
you physically as you can even if it's a
huge difference in margin difference in
price because we are trying to do in the
beginning is prove a model you're not
trying to necessarily make money so if
you can if you if it costs eighty
percent more to do it in your hometown
then doing it overseas I say do it in
your hometown where you can watch it be
there touch me and they don't have the
surprises the big thing that kills you
is manufacturing and especially from a
far-off place is the surprise when it
comes not being what you thought it is
and by that time it's too late right so
the nice thing is is is if it or you
just move to wherever your manufacturing
I mean one of my favorite you know
entrepreneurs is Fernando in Santiago
who started Reif sandals and these are
Argentines actually as well that I got
to know through the years being in the
shoe business and and Santiago moved to
Brazil and lived like at the factory for
those early years of reef to literally
watch every shoe being made and that's
why their quality was so good and that's
why they built such a great company so
sometimes if you can't make it locally
you go there but manufacturing is where
most I would say these businesses never
get off the ground or end up imploding
just because you just do one strike and
you're out together that well that's the
case where you really have to have boots
on the ground yeah I was talking to a
buddy of mine who's the founder or maybe
co-founder of a apparel brand called
Sitka okay it's kind of like if you want
to think the Lululemon for hunting and
outdoor gear okay really high quality
stuff and he went to try to for the same
reason yeah
this food guy I've had some some drinks
with him and the way that he negotiated
this terms that he needed because
they're like can't be done no like
everything's gonna be late similar
situation oh my god this is an
existential crisis okay so I went to
China and he sat there in their
translator and they're doing like cheers
I cheers to the steer to the Chairman
cheers so this means like do they have
to drink every time I do a Cheers
mmm in the trailers like yes they'd be
rude not yeah yeah he's like okay so we
can just officially everybody completely
lists and then the big boss is like
definitely next week no problem there
are courtside so you gotta cheer on time
anyway not mine recommended negotiating
tactic necessarily their books and so on
you could read if I lost the material
possessions or the wealth or the ability
to do some of the things that my family
gets to do you know it kind of goes back
to what Tim was saying the guy with the
sleeping bag and the oatmeal like I feel
like I've you know there's enough people
that would help me get that oatmeal on
that backpack and that sleeping bag and
and me and my family would probably
still live a great life I mean the thing
that I've learned the most I think it's
most from my travels around the world
and I've been to every country and seen
almost every hardship that that is
imaginable is sometimes the people who
are living the most poverty the most
rural are also the happiest and the
reason is the reason is is because their
life is so simple that they spend their
time in relationships like it's amazing
to see I'm very close with many families
in Ethiopia because we spend a lot of
time there we do manufacturing there and
when you get to rural Ethiopia you see
the amount of time that they are
suspending laughter and games and
playing and it's because there's there's
not much else to do because they don't
have anything else like I mean you know
I mean basically they're only daily
towards making sure they have water and
food and other than that it's just all
about relationship and loving on one
another and so I think that you know
it's a tricky time we live in now
because we get caught in the cycle
having to you know to support these
lifestyles that we create and oftentimes
there's been so much money trying to do
that that we don't end up enjoying the
life that we have and so I will say that
that's one thing that in my maturing and
learning and studying over the years I
have gotten much better at and put much
more premium on and I don't work eleven
months you know lights out and then just
for that one month off anymore
I make sure that I am experiencing
yesterday yeah textbooks just open it
texted me does it have a pre call and I
was surfing all day in Santa Barbara
didn't have my phone on didn't get back
to until 10 o'clock at night because I
was like you know what like I had a
couple really long days before this I
want to have a lot of fresh energy for
this today so I took the whole day went
surfing one of my best friends and you
know spend time all morning with my son
and so those are the things that are
important and it knows and I didn't
always realize that so so I think that
you know you really you can't lose
everything when what you care about are
the people in the memories yes ladies
and gentlemen Blake Mycoskie oh hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday is that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and 500 Friday
is a very short email where I share the
coolest things I found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
have somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric
as I do it could include favorite
articles that I have read and that I've
shared with my close friends for
instance and it's very short it's just a
little tiny bite of goodness before you
head off for the weekend so if you want
to receive that check it out just go to
4-hour work week calm
4-hour workweek calm all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one and if you sign up I
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for years
for all sorts of graphic design needs
whether you need a logo website cover
anything else 99 designs was created to
make great designs accessible to
everyone
to make the process of getting design
much much easier so when I first started
out for instance testing prototype of
covers and getting prototype covers for
the 4-hour body I want a contest drop
that is one object this is a great
solution if you're looking for fast
affordable design work and the ability
to choose from dozens of options
risk-free let's say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other time zones other countries can
also help you solve that problem since
then I've worked with 99 designs on a
separate path or a different option and
that is the one-to-one project service
so in a number of cases and I'll give
you one example when I wanted to create
the cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied
they lighted iterate with I'd feedback
and all this stuff and I haven't shared
it yet we also got something incredibly
good really some of the best
illustrations I've ever seen from using
this one-to-one project service with a
handful of different designers and
illustrators it blew my mind 99 designs
makes this all very easy and efficient
so you can check out the town of Seneca
design and other work that I and your
fellow listeners for that matter have
done on 99 designs at 99 designs comm
forward slash Tim and right now you can
get a free $99 upgrade on your first
design again that's 99 designs com4
slash Tim this episode is brought to you
by Intel I've used them personally ever
since I wrote the 4-hour workweek
I've been asked over and over again how
I choose to delegate tasks how I do
80/20 analysis and so on at the root of
many of those decisions is a simple
question actually two questions number
one how can I invest money to improve my
quality of life is an investing as well
the second how can I spend a little
money or moderate money to save
significant Intel is one of those
investments they're a turnkey solution
for all of your imaginable customer care
needs
I used Intel during the launch of the
4-hour body which was very very involved
and they provided 24/7 customer service
for my landrush campaign because it was
critical for me to take care of every
person who purchased my books and
participating this allows me to focus on
the things that I am better at my
strengths like a marketing plan that
we've worked on for six months
implementing that Intel trains their
experience customer service reps to know
your business and your products inside
now and make your customers raving fans
they answer more than a million customer
service requests every year and they can
do so across all platforms including
email phone social media text even chat
leaving your customers with poor service
or just mediocre service which by the
way in a competitive pool the huge
liability long wait times or unanswered
messages carries a massive cost and risk
to your business Intel removes the
logistics and headaches of this type of
communication allowing you to focus on
your strengths and grow your business it
can be a real competitive advantage and
I see many many e-commerce companies and
companies thinking of customer service
as a good enough check box or an
afterthought and just like Airbnb use
design and innovative ways to be a
competitor and to win you can do the
same thing with customer service so as a
listener of this podcast you can get up
to ten thousand dollars off the discount
ten thousand dollars off your startup
fees and costs by visiting in telecom
forward slash Tim so check it out for
more info go to Inc health.com i NK t PL
com forward slash tip
you
[Applause]